one of the things I love about summer is
the fact that I know most people during
summer when this Sun comes out get
casual they get comfortable they leave
30 minutes earlier from what they don't
stay late I gotta go home but also
during that summer season every single
time in my career if you look at my
sales months the biggest months of my
career have intentionally been during
summer time because I just know what
happens during summer times instead of
having a weekly challenge for you I've
got a summer challenge for you with five
books I want you to read before
September 1st these five books the goal
is by the time you get back to work on
September 1st obviously your work in
summertime but by September 1st the goal
is for your peers your competitors all
the people you work with on a daily
basis your relatives
no one's gonna recognize you have to
read these five books no more mr. nice
guy
let me tell you why I want you to read
the book no more mr. nice guy no more
mr. nice guy is a book about how men
have become babies because the last
generation of men were raised by their
mothers what two three generations ago
boys were raised by their sons on farms
so because of that a lot has changed on
how men are today versus how we were 80
90 years ago so when you read it you're
gonna look at in a whole different way
by the way I recommend men and women to
read this book because it'll shift your
mindset I've probably recommended this
book to a couple hundred guys and when I
do after they read it they say did you
recommend this book because you were
thinking about me I said well you know
kind of yes so you're either gonna read
this and you gonna say wait a minute
stop talking about me if the shoe fits
I'm probably talking about you but if it
doesn't you'll at least get an
understanding about how men are wired
after you read this book called no more
mr. nice guy
number four book it's called strategy
here's why I like this book it's a big
book you can listen to the audiobook but
here's what I want you to read this book
in the game of business I talked about
four things right I'll twerk out and
prove out last out strategize right out
strategize comes last because you have
to figure out a lot of different things
you do that doesn't work this book you
read
you're gonna read any gonna say oh my
gosh this makes a lot of sense that the
strategy they use in war and politics of
every single industry he shares you
different strategies that were used in
every industry religion Hollywood every
possible way and you're gonna sit there
and say this guy's use that on me before
I've used this before not known about it
but by the time you're done
you're gonna get two or three strategies
to use from September first on to have a
killer 2018 and finish off the year on a
high note now number three principals by
Ray Dalio listen if you haven't yet read
it you got to go to the bookstore and
order immediately this could have been a
number one book but you will know why I
put a certain book number one Ray Dalio
breaks down the concept of how to build
the right principles and values in your
business in ways I've never read in
another book before not telling you now
we're at 1,500 business books the way he
breaks it down is a book it's the reason
why I had every one of my sales guys in
the company read it every one of our
sales vice presidents read it every one
of my President's Council Chairman's
counsel read it and every employee at
our Home Office and they wrote a report
on it it's that powerful of a book it's
500 pages but by the time you're done
reading it you will not look at business
leadership management any of that stuff
the same way ever again
number two skin in the game now let me
tell you why I like this book when I
read this book I read it again it was
recommended by multiple different people
I like this book because he challenges
everybody politician family religions
but he challenges every single
conventional thinking and he says why do
you have an opinion about how things
should be done if you don't have skin in
the game you've got to listen to it
because it'll help with your argument as
you're speaking to people in your
company it just will strengthen a lot of
your arguments that you have in your
life against skin the game must read
book and last but not least the number
one book to read this summer the art of
the deal by Donald Trump
I didn't say president Donald Trump it's
Donald Trump why because when he wrote
it
he wasn't hated like he is today both
Republicans Democrats independents
libertarians liked him because there was
no politics involved people don't like
him today because now they're realizing
what his political beliefs are whether
it was Reagan whether it was Bush
whether it was Clinton anybody I want to
know how you're wired and how you're
thinking I want to consume your content
when you read this book art of the deal
won your negotiation will improve number
two you will know exactly who your
president is why he's having these types
of meeting with g7 that they're coming
back and having all this controversy
with this picture this famous picture
that you will see that'll be shown for
decades few hundred years from now
people are going to show this picture
about President Donald Trump when you
look at them at the meeting and you got
the hands down saying what are you doing
why are you making this thing so
difficult because he's negotiating
whatever you wanted
and what they don't realize is he is the
master negotiator amongst everybody
because he's been doing this for so many
years so if you don't own any of these
five books click on the link below in
the description you'll go straight to
Amazon order the five books and bottle
if you've read any of these books and
you got some input on what you liked
about it I want to hear from you what
did you like about one of these five
books that you read send me a tweet at
Patrick made David honor what you took
away from one of these five books with
that being said if you haven't
subscribed to this channel click on the
sub button enjoy reading these five
books this summer take care
[Music]